[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
premier set 8 culture de la saison un
numéro entièrement consacré aux journées
du patrimoine qui se tiendront les 16 et
17 septembre prochains
tout de suite le sommaire des visites
des expositions des conférences les
communes de 50 ans divine ouvre toutes
leurs portes
nous ferons le point sur la
programmation un autre site qui vous ses
portes le château de rambouillet après
deux ans de fermeture pour travaux le
lieu de repos de marie antoinette et du
général de gaulle a fait peau neuve et
ses journées du patrimoine sont aussi
l'occasion de fêter un anniversaire
celui du théâtre montansier l'envers du
décor et son histoire sont à découvrir
en plateau ce soir avec nous trois
invités armelle o'brien vice présidente
de saint quentin en yvelines en charge
de la culture
en clair un rôles chargée d'action
éducative au domaine de rambouillet et
geneviève dichamp qui nous rejoindra
dans quelques instants la codirectrice
du théâtre montansier de versailles
alors nous allons bien sûr parler de
déprogrammation alors difficile de tout
présenté ce soir mais tout au long de
nos échanges et site internet
s'afficheront en bas de l'écran
je veux tourner d'abord vers vous armelo
brillé cette année encore une
programmation riche sur l'agglomération
une visite du campus universitaire une
exposition éphémère à l'espace de covile
et des visites à la commanderie des
templiers
oui à la commanderie des templiers des
visites particulières puisque ce sont
des parcours départ côté des jeux en
fait qu'ils sont ouverts ou c'est bien
pour les enfants à partir de 4 ans
puisque ça sera fait repartir d'image et
puis après pour les plus grands il y
aura 10 et des énigmes etc
et c'est le moment de découvrir la
commanderie des templiers qui est qui
justifie le label art et histoire de
saint quentin
puisqu'il ya eu des templiers il ya eu
la guerre de cent ans puis ça a été
transformée en ferme pour devenir
un lieu culturel et c'est le moment de
découvrir tout ça c'est un lieu qui
d'habitude accueille surtout des
expositions là on va vous parler de
l'histoire
il a refusé normalement on fait les deux
c'est à dire quand même fait des visites
au moins une fente armand de la
commanderie des templiers
mais effectivement on l'a on va axer
toutes ces journées du patrimoine sur le
parcours de la commanderie des templiers
alors avant de parler des as tu du pro
am je propose des côtes et un court
extrait pendant que vous vous éparpillez
on écoute ma dame des landes architecte
avec son mari du quartier 17 mar alors
cette voix c'est celle du chorégraphe
david rolland il lance une api manif
dans le quartier 17 mar à elancourt un
partenariat entre le prisme et le musée
de la ville et nous l'avons rencontré
[Musique]
david rolland bonjour bonjour alors vous
êtes le créateur de happy manif une
déambulation chorégraphique à travers
les villes découverte joyeuse et décalé
qui se fait qu'un casque audio et sur
des circuits
c'est bien ça exactement alors d'où vous
est venue l'idée
ben ça fait très longtemps que je fais
des spectacles participatifs donc qui
met le spectateur en jeu et est un
théâtre avait où il dire cela et il m'a
fait une commande plutôt d'une bande son
qui faisait les et qu'ils faisaient
voilà c'était à rennes avec le triangle
à rennes et ça a été ma première
déambulation comme ça donc en écrivant
une bande sonore dans lequel il ya des
musiques et aussi ma voix qui va
indiquer déjà où se diriger dans la
ville et ensuite je parle de la ville
et puis ça parle aussi du collectif
puisque c'est une centaine de personnes
à la fois qu'ils se baladent qu'est-ce
que sur la tête et le tout sur un ton
vraiment burlesque ça y est voilà j'aime
bien manier l'humour et et faire que le
groupe était bien là bien la banane
alors vos appuis manif ondes et mg
parallèle et celle du 16 septembre se
nomme la croisée des arts
alors effectivement c'est une commande
du prisme à elancourt de la ville je
crois bien qu'ils autour de donc c'est
les journées du patrimoine
donc le quartier 17 mars de ces années
70 donc c'est déjà du patrimoine et
architecturalement et au niveau des
oeuvres d'art dans là ville il ya
beaucoup à dire et beaucoup tu as
raconté
voilà donc j'ai récupéré des interviews
des des architectes monsieur madame dès
le lendemain dame des landes de
l'artiste de la main divine qui est la
main qui est derrière le prisme donc
voilà on va se balader dans la ville
tout en découvrant redécouvrant
et puis j'aime bien aussi attiré
l'attention sur des détails qui sont pas
forcément du patrimoine quoi l'idée
c'est de faire voyager les gens
voulaient fait bouger tout le monde a la
même bande sonore vous fait des
interactions à ça c'est un secret mais
oui on découvre très vite qu'ils aillent
à deux groupes différents qui entendent
des choses différentes parce qu'il
permet déjà que les groupes se croisent
ne fasse pas les mêmes actions que les
actions des groupes se complètent et
voilà ça crée un dialogue en soit entre
deux personnes
entre deux et ça rajoute un peu à à
cette atmosphère que j'aime joyeuse en
fais est ce qu'il ya un âge pour y
participer à des conditions peut-être
physique
on va dire que à partir de 7-8 ans le
casque commence à bien tenir sur la tête
des petits voilà et même dans la
compréhension des indications voilà huit
ans et 8 ans c'est bien et ça dure et ça
dure une quarantaine de minutes
exactement
merci beaucoup alors pour découvrir le
quartier 17 mar autrement rendez vous le
16 septembre
deux départs sont prévus 14h et 16h on
continue avec nos invités on reste pour
moment sur saint quentin en yvelines
tusk à maurepas l'association mort pas
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui fait découvrir
la ville heureuse oui cette association
cette fête qui est 50 ans de la bio
creuse donc c'était l'architecte jacques
riboud qui avait commencé par construire
quelque chose à villepreux
ce qui a plu au maire de meaux pas et
donc
ils sont partis sur au lieu de faire des
barres horizontales en a fait des vins
des maisons des effectivement aussi du
collectif mais ouvert sur la verdure les
oeuvres d'art qui étaient conçus au
milieu d'eux au milieu de la
construction que l'on allait faire et c
est du coup la ville nouvelle s'est
inspiré de ce parcours pourquoi essayer
de faire quelque chose
donc là c'est une visite qui va durer de
14h à 18h longue visite avant il ya
d'autres nous avons joint plateau et
geneviève dichamp bonsoir codirectrice
du théâtre montansier on parlera avec
vous de ce qu'on va pouvoir découvrir ce
week-end armelle au brier la visite va
plutôt à maurepas va plutôt être
architectural oui je sais plus je sais
plus le en fait oui c'est l'
architecture au sens large puisqu'il ya
les oeuvres d'art puisqu'il ya la
construction de la verdure
il n'y a pas collé comme le bâtiment
c'est tout un concept urbain en fait qui
va être rude mais c'est ce côté là delà
de la ville de la ville nouvelle en fait
que l'on va découvrir et qui est très
qui est très important parce que c'est
quand même assez caractéristique est
singulier de ski saint quentin en
yvelines alors 50 ans chez moore pas un
autre anniversaire m était beaucoup plus
grand en termes d'âge c'est celui donc
du théâtre montansier à versailles
si je me trompe pas il était inauguré en
1770 7 18 novembre
deux cent quarante ans alors l'histoire
de ce château 4 il a été construit par
marguerite brunet qui après avoir
recherché plusieurs endroits dans
versailles fini par réussir à acheter un
terrain dit des chiens de verre qui
appartient au frère du roi elle le
mobilise boulet qui est un machiniste de
l'opéra royal et elle réussit à
construire en quelques mois ce théâtre
qui a l'originalité d'être dit à
l'italienne qui a un rapport scène-salle
étonnant et qui sera ça veut dire
l'ovale est parfait voilà et que ça
produit donc une acoustique tout à fait
étonnante et ce théâtre est destiné dès
l'origine à accueillir le public par la
rue des réservoirs
mais le roi et la reine viennent par un
ancien passage qui avait été réalisé
pour la pompadour puisque son hôtel et
juste au dessus et donc assistent au
spectacle dans une loge qui demeure
toujours un jardin fils est très proche
ils jalonnent sur le bassin de neptune
alors pour ces journées du patrimoine il
ya trois rendez vous on va préciser un
l'un d'entre eux d'abord une visite
libre
c'est à dire qu'ils vont pour elle et le
public va pouvoir passer dans les
coulisses voilà le public va pouvoir
voir la salle dans laquelle on déploie
un rideau peint par ce violent d'sa qui
était un peintre décorateur qui a
beaucoup travaillé notamment pour la
scala de milan
et puis ils pourront se rendre au foyer
dans lequel on propose des photographies
du théâtre et puis on voit là iront les
laisse libres
à cette occasion on organise des visites
dans l'allée mais là en l'occurrence on
les laisse libres parce qu'on a aussi le
sentiment que ce jour là le public a
envie d'accumuler le nombre de le plus
grand nombre possible de visite aura
versailles a beaucoup beaucoup
d'endroits à visiter et justement ça
permettra de découvrir pourquoi le
théâtre a été classé monument historique
en 1991
alors je vous propose de faire une
petite pause avec nos invités en parce
qu'on va partir à la découverte d'un
autre lieu classé au patrimoine un
jardin qui a plus de 300 ans
il se trouve à magny les hameaux dans le
domaine de boue et si susan et françois
bursaux les propriétaires nous le font
visiter regardez ici on a de la nette
qui monte en fleurs on a de la roquette
à our global on les italiens il ya des
navettes
hier à l'abri des regards à magny les
hameaux
une histoire qui dure celle du domaine
de brou essayer de son jardin construit
en 1711 est classé monument historique
le plan du jardin c'est à dire cette
grande allée est une des deux croisés et
l'origine on le voit sur les premiers
plans ce qui est assez remarquable
ce qui a changé ce sont des arbres en
espagne et qui sont qui sont devenus à
la mode plutôt au début du 19e siècle
car les arbres étaient en gobelets avant
imaginée par pierre cailleteau de
l'assurance le jardin suit les préceptes
de jean baptiste de la quintinie
architecte de louis xiv le jardin aux
portes
elle allait l'aller parfaitement droites
visible de la maison l'alimentation en
eau dans le coin oraux pour que l'on
puisse l'opus descendre la fermeture de
murs pour protéger et surtout une
exposition une protection des vents
dominants de l'ouest puisque même dans
les pires tempêtes qu'on a pu connu le
jardin ne bouge pas un jardin et un
domaine aux habitants illustre les vice
comme paul ancien maire de magny les
hameaux de 1935 et 1940 où l'une de ses
filles une certaine louise weiss
journaliste écrivain et européennes on
continue à parler des journées du
patrimoine avec nos invités avant de
faire un petit tour du côté de
rambouillet
vos trois communes ou agglomérations
sont proches les unes des autres
est ce qu'un jour des journées du
patrimoine pourrait voir des circuits
qui concernerait tous vos trois lieux il
y aurait de quoi faire mais je pense
qu'on trouve facilement des passerelles
à des passerelles entre nous après c'est
vrai que le jour de ses journées on sent
que les gens ont aussi envie si la météo
est clémente de se promener à pied et de
rentrer dans des endroits dans qui
connaissent mais dans lesquels ils
accèdent page est d'habitude parce que
d'entendre est il trop l'invaincu
circuit très bon quand même très long à
penser peut-être pour les années futures
mais à travailler justement le château
de rambouillet alterné roll il rouvre
ses portes après deux ans de fermeture
eh oui
on a eu une grosse grosse campagne de
restauration des extérieurs du château
qui a débuté en 2014 à peu près mené par
le centre des monuments nationaux et
aujourd'hui enfin on peut effectivement
réouvrir les portes et de façon assez
exceptionnelle parce qu'on accueille en
partenariat avec le château de
versailles une belle exposition de
portraits du xviiie siècle de la famille
des bourbons penthièvre donc vraiment
quelque chose qui qui va mettre un peu
en valeur voilà cette réouverture et
puis le château et et sont passés assez
glorieux
je le faisais dans les titres un lieu de
repos pour certains grands personnalités
politiques historiques et politiques
oui tout à fait
c'est un domaine qui est
particulièrement bien placé parce qu'on
a une forêt très giboyeuse aux alentours
donc évidemment tous les grands
personnages de l'histoire ont fini par
avoir envie d'y chasser il disait
journée et c'est le cas notamment du roi
louis saez qui décide d'en faire une
résidence royale en 1783 et à partir de
là il faut compter tous les grands
napoléon 1er napoléon iii les présidents
de la république et voilà de brandon
l'hôtel des journées cette année du
patrimoine c'est l'enfance la jeunesse
armelle ouvriers nous le disait tout à
l'heure à la commanderie y aura des jeux
de piste spéciaux pour les enfants chez
vous il ya de l'escrim du croquet et du
tir est lâchée avec vos enfants
oui alors l'idée là c'est de rebondir
justement sur 7 sur cette exposition
qu'on réalise sur le 18è siècle
finalement et c'est de se dire mais
voilà l'enfant au xviiie siècle en parle
peu importe qu'elles en font un celui de
la noblesse évidemment le prince comme
le duc de penthièvre qu'elle était
finalement son éducation qu'est-ce qu'il
apprenait comment et du coût de cette
idée
est parti
la mise en place de jeux de jeux
d'époque en extérieur on parle bien du
croquet qu'on a appelé le jeu de maille
au xviiie siècle
et puis il ya aussi évidemment les
scream qui tenait une place importante
voilà donc plein de plein de belles
choses avec des bots partenariat aussi
puisqu'on travaille avec la les fossés
la ligue d'escrimé artistique d'île de
france ouest et qui vient avec ses
élèves et son maître d'armes jean louis
boulet pour nous faire de belles
démonstrations je pense que ça va valoir
le coup mais il faut il faut qu'il y ait
du soleil mais ça je pense que c'est
pour nous tout ça on a besoin de soleil
à cette journée l'enfance et j'en ai du
patrimoine d'avoir le thème de l'enfance
et c'est un très bon thème cette année
parce que faire découvrir le patrimoine
comme ça vous enfoncez nécessaire c'est
leur culture c'est la page de leur
construction s'apercevoir quand même
qu'ils arrivent de quelque part et qu'on
fait avancer les choses oui je pense que
j'ai très important j'ai même dû changer
d et tout à l'heure il ya trois
rendez-vous ce week-end dans le cadre
des journées on a parlé des visites
il y a aussi des lectures marie
christine barrault le samedi lire à
madame de sévigné et manuel noblet
récemment récompensé d'un molière des
lettres de kafka absolument lettre au
père on s'est associé au festival de
grignan festival de la correspondance
qui constitue valcke a lieu pendant le
mois de juillet pour proposer donc deux
rendez vous pendant ces journées
européennes du patrimoine et faire
entendre de la littérature ou montansier
avec de beaux comédiens magazine
marocain que tout le monde apprécie
émanait noblet qui est un communiqué que
nous aimons beaucoup puisque nous avons
été producteur de réparer les vivants
qui vous savez est un succès important
et qui reprit la au petit saint martin
pour trois mois que je vous recommande
d'aller voir
en clair on a beaucoup orienter le
château jusqu'à présent les autres lieux
du domaine seront à découvrir ce week
end
oui tout à fait on ouvre à la visite
libre de découverte libre la laiterie de
la reine marie antoinette et la
chaumière aux coquillages
évidemment on s'est vraiment de deux
monuments qui sont fabulation le domaine
de rambouillet on n'en parle pas assez
il n'y a pas que le château sur le
domaine
royal il ya aussi ces deux fabriques de
jardin
que vous dire sinon quand on visite ces
monuments on se retrouve vraiment
plonger dans l'atmosphère du xviiie et
pauvre je pense c'est les bols de marie
antoinette
je sais c'est vraiment vraiment à faire
et c'est une découverte à faire aussi
avec les enfants parce que pour le coup
on est dans des monuments à taille
humaine et et on voit souvent que la
réaction des enfants et parfois plus
importante que quand on est dans un
château est vraiment voilà qu'il faut le
faire c'est important d'avoir profité
des journées du patrimoine pour pouvoir
circuler librement dans ces espaces qui
normalement sont visitables en visite
guidée en plus alors on va clore cette
page sur les journées du patrimoine on
va repartir à saint quentin en yvelines
armelle au brier l'agglomération a
choisi de parler des oeuvres sociales
on en trouve qu'ils sont à destination
des enfants il y aura un itinéraire de
bus un petit mot parce qu'on partira va
suivre lucie sauvageau qui le connaît il
ya un parcours de bus qui sache et qui
sera suivie d'une conférence et d'un
concert qui organisé avec la société
d'histoire de villepreux et l'assistance
publique
on aura aussi une exposition l'enfant
dans la ville à l'espace des conduites
ses voisins et puis la balade guidée sur
les traces de l'enfant sous quartier de
villars waaagh inc ou alors c'est aussi
important de montrer cette évolution de
l'enfance et justement l'enfance
l'assistance sociale les oeuvres
sociales pour les enfants à saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est le projet c'est le programme du de
l'itinéraire un début c'est regarder
lucie sauvageau nous en dit un peu plus
que faire des enfants abandonnés des
jeunes délinquants
une préoccupation au 19e siècle lié à la
révolution industrielle
une paupérisation de la population le
musée de la ville tend à la faire
connaître à elancourt un orphelinat la
fondation méquignon une abbaye est un
lieu emblématique sa chapelle qui dit
abbaye dit forcément un lieu de culte
donc cette chapelle qui était qu'avec
pierre d'autel évidemment à la base on
était célébré des messes à laquelle
assistaient les orphelins de l'abbaye et
puis l'abbaye en elle même était tenu
par départ des bonnes soeurs dirigé par
au départ par la soeur gabrielle qui est
cofondatrice avec l'abbé méquignon de ce
lieu donc cette chapelle elle était
vraiment centrale pour la demie c'était
c'était le centre du domaine et autour
d'elle a été les établissements
d'accueil des enfants la belle méquignon
turé d'elancourt créer son orphelinat
dès 1859
la fondation est reconnue d'utilité
publique en 1866 donc là on va aller
voir et donc centre de formation aux
métiers du bâtiment de ville prononça
c'est l'affectation actuelle
le légal une idée de formation déjà
présente 130 ans plus tôt l'école
d'horticulture le nôtre est fondée en
1882 sur le modèle des oeuvres de
georges bonjean un juge qu'ils
considéraient les enfants délinquants
comme des victimes
elle prendra le nom du célèbre jardinier
vert pâle en 1896 et elle fonctionnera
jusqu'en 1963 comme école d'horticulture
donc cette école elle avait
bien sûr des salles de classe comme
toutes les écoles mais surtout un parc
et dessert pour apprendre aux enfants à
jardiner et parlent à leur apprendre les
vertus de la terre il ya tout aussi une
idée de que la terre est bénéfique par
rapport à l'univers urbain qui lui est
plus vicieux et vicieux où un huissier
un jardin à la française un l'anglais ce
dessert il n'en reste aujourd'hui que ce
bassin quelques autres rendez vous à ne
pas manquer pour ces journées du
patrimoine la maison des étudiants
martha panne est à découvrir le samedi
16 septembre lors de visites guidées
mais mort de trac propose des animations
pour découvrir l'histoire et l'urbanisme
de la ville durant une après-midi à
voisins le bretonneux c'est un interlude
musical qui vous attend dans le parc de
la croix du bois seront joués des pièces
de bach et de mozart et l'association
des amis du patrimoine plaisir wa vous
emmène dans les coulisses du château de
la commune à versailles vous pourrez
visiter des lieux inédits comme la cour
d'appel mais aussi des sites culturels
tels que le centre de musique baroque ou
la bibliothèque de leurs joyeuses et
tout le week-end ce sont les domaines de
madame elisabeth et le musée lambinet
qui propose des visites guidées
les plus jeunes ne sont pas oubliés les
petits détectives sont attendus à la
cour des senteurs on passe maintenant à
notre coup de coeur
[Musique]
le premier coup de coeur de la saison
c'est celui de gaël pineau du grenier à
sel de trappes pour l'écoutent
bonjour c'est la rentrée aussi au cinéma
le grenier à sel donc pour commencer
l'année nous avons deux événements vous
présenter le premier c'est la projection
de metropolis qui est dans le cadre des
lumières de grenier notre projection de
films de patrimoine
ce sera le vendredi 22 septembre à 20
heures la projection sera précédée d'une
présentation par l'os de l'association
contre chant etc le film
le plus important de l'histoire du
cinéma hamon
à mon avis ne manquez pas donc
métropolis le vendredi 22 septembre à
20h00 le deuxième film c'est kobe kobe
c'est un documentaire de réalisé par
christian 60 de rigueur et c'est un film
qui est très personnel très touchant
c'est l'histoire de son frère qui était
une femme et qui a décidé de changer de
sexe
donc en suisse est ce changement vous
inquiétez pas il ya quelque chose de
très pudique il n'y a absolument pas
d'opération etc
on suit juste l'évolution de cette cette
femme cette transformation
ce sera le vendredi 29 septembre à 20h45
le réalisateur sera là ce week-end ce ne
sont pas que les journées du patrimoine
à un rendez vous à noter le dimanche
c'est aussi la foire à la brocante à
guyancourt et à cette occasion praline
gay para qui est en résidence à la ferme
de bel ébat lira ses contes nomades sa
caravane rouge vous attend et si vous
êtes musiciens amateurs ou confirmés la
nourrice de trappes recherche de
nouveaux talents pour la deuxième
édition de fait des groupes qui aura
lieu le 18 novembre prochain
les candidatures sont à faire jusqu'au
15 octobre
le 7-8 culture est maintenant terminée
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis le
magazine est à retrouver sur notre site
internet ou sur l'application tv 78 je
vous dis à mercredi prochain
[Musique]